let's get more on what exactly is in the
Senate's bailout bill we're joined now
by CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger Jill good morning so we're
talking about $1,200 for most Americans
three hundred and fifty billion dollars
for small businesses and an expansion of
unemployment insurance is that enough
well we'll see the economists that I
speak to believe that there will be
another package that will have to be
passed as you know for most people this
is a lifeline more than anything else
we're gonna have to understand just how
deep this recession that we're most
likely in already goes and more
importantly for how long it lasts I
thought one really great feature of this
was the extension of unemployment
benefits for an extra four months but
also that it included independent
contractors and gig workers people who
are usually excluded from claiming
unemployment benefits that is a very big
deal well this is really good news to
hear but how does all this cash Jil
stimulate the economy if all of so many
businesses are shut down
I think that we should really wreak a is
this is really not a stimulus bill this
is a lifeline and a lifeline to
businesses to individuals some of that
money will be spent but a lot of this is
simply survival mode we know the economy
is going to take a hit so if we really
think about this more is this is our
lifeline in order to allow the economy
to bounce back this is not stimulative
in nature
all right many people grabbing a
lifeline right now thank you very much
Joe